largas esperas y un recinto desbordado
marcan el panorama del departamento de
pasaportes en afganistán luego de que la
oficina abriera tras un mes de cierre es
debido al hacinamiento y varios
problemas técnicos la afluencia de
personas ha llevado a los talibanes a
hacer un llamado a la calma
pedimos a todos los solicitantes que
esperen hasta el 10 de enero de 2022 ya
que estamos procesando a muchas personas
y a partir de entonces podremos aceptar
nuevas solicitudes en kabul y otras
provincias la alta demanda responde a la
búsqueda de muchos afganos que obtener
sus pasaportes para salir del país entre
ellos estudiantes y personas que
requieren tratamientos médicos
especializados un intento muchas veces
truncado está saturado hay muchos
solicitantes y es difícil controlar todo
no podemos decir que los servicios sean
buenos pero la gente no tiene la opción
y sigue viniendo aquí en paralelo 57
naciones islámicas y observadores se
reunieron en islamabad pakistán buscando
fondos para financiar ayuda humanitaria
unos recursos que podrían aliviar la
precarización de la situación en el país
de la que alertan los talibanes debido a
la congelación de la ayuda financiera de
los países occidentales
si la situación política y económica en
afganistán no cambia habrá incluso más
gente que se irá del país lo que será un
problema para los países vecinos y para
europa misma
según la agencia para los refugiados de
la onu desde que comenzó el año más de
500.000 55 personas han sido obligadas a
dejar el país